Welcome everybody to another Zoom call.
We will just jump in and get started here.
Just a reminder for you to know that you can self-schedule.
Please, if you self-schedule, make sure you fill out that coaching protocol form.
There's a button right out there. This is on our website and on the member site, multiple places.
Let's get into the questions.
You mentioned several times the dangers of running pro-wave frequencies through the bulb setting.
But the other day I realized I ran the iron pro-wave settings with the pro-wave attached.
The pro-wave was blinking as usual.
Is that also damaging the right?
I think what you're saying is the bulb settings with the pro-wave attached.
Or did you mean I ran the iron pro-wave with the bulb attached?
You'd always run the pro-wave with the pro-wave attached.
So, the thing that's yet to be careful of is that on the true right, you need the switch to bath when you run the iron pro-wave.
So, you said yes, the switch was set to bulb.
So, if you ran the iron pro-wave with the switch set to bulb, because you have the iron pro-wave plugged in, it still may blink.
But it doesn't mean that the frequencies are coming out of there and there's any energy that's going to it.
Can you damage the iron pro-wave by having it set to bulb and running iron pro-wave settings?
Well, you will damage the iron pro-wave, but you could damage the bulb.
So, if you didn't have the bulb connected, which you should always leave the bulb connected.
But if you didn't have the bulb connected, and you ran an iron pro-wave program with your iron pro-wave plugged in,
and had it switched to bulb by accident while you were running the iron pro-wave, you would probably get our keep that go between these two little ports here.
You'd be going back and forth on the red and black, and if you touched it, you'd get a shock.
You always should have your bulb plugged in when you run the iron pro-wave.
You should always have the bulb plugged in when you run the iron pro-wave, and of course you have the bulb plugged in when you run the bulb program.
So, you risk damaging the bulb when you run an iron pro-wave program, but you have this switched to bulb.
And the reason is the bath has the iron pro-wave programs have different duty cycles, and you risk burning out the cord, you risk burning out, you know, damaging your bulb in some way.
Now, if you just didn't want to chance you damage your bulb, it's probably zero.
But if you did this on a regular basis, then you could damage the bulb.
But you'd notice that it won't work, or the cord is damaged, or it smells burned.
There's a burned smell or something like that.
So, if it's working just fine after this, you go, oh my gosh, did I just ruin something?
Because I had this switched to bulb the whole time.
Well, if you turn back on to a bulb program, and you leave it on switched to bulb when you do that, obviously.
And it's running just fine, and you don't have any of those issues that you didn't damage anything, but you do risk that damage.
So, always when you're running the iron pro-wave, you have this switched to bath.
When you're running the bulb, you have a switched to bulb, and at all times you have your bulb plugged in.
Now, this is the older F-122 model, and just a couple of questions later, there's another question about the difference between them, so I'll get to that.
I'm thinking of buying some small fruit trees to get clean fruit in a few years.
How important is it to buy trees that are organic trees, like organic apple trees, from the start, versus conventional trees that you might get at the hardware store or something?
If we buy conventional will this synthetics be out in a few years by the time the tree matures and we get fruit?
Or if we buy conventional will the young trees struggle without the synthetics they were started on?
So, we planted, you know, we do a lot of gardening, I think that's why this question was asked.
We planted different fruit trees, and you can buy organic apple trees.
I don't know about any of the other fruit trees, but I have seen the organic apple trees.
Now, in truth, is it important to buy an organic tree?
My answer to that is, I don't think so.
I don't think it's important to buy an organic tree.
Now, what's the difference between an organic tree and an non-organic tree?
Well, the non-organic conventional grown tree probably had been sprayed at some point in time.
But in truth, if you're buying a tree that is, you know, the diameter of the tree is an inch to an inch and a half thick, which is typically a lot of fruit trees, the chance that they sprayed it with something is zero.
They didn't spray with anything. They're not trying to get fruit.
Therefore, you know, they're not spraying these trees.
So, I don't think there's an issue with that.
Even if they did spray the trees for apples, for the worms, to keep, you know, they would be picking the fruit off of an egg.
You know, they don't want the trees to be fruity, so I don't even think they would spend the money to buy the spray to spray the trees.
So, I do not think it's important to buy or to spend, you know, three times the price to get an organic apple tree.
If you're going to grow it organically, like our apple trees, we never spray them.
We never do anything to them.
And yeah, we get some warby apples.
We don't even, you know, there's a whole bunch of different tricks that you could do by putting apple cider vinegar and pops out on your tree and hang them, hang them from your tree and things like that.
We don't even do that.
So, we get tons and tons of apples.
We can, tons of apples, we made, we had so many apples, we'd juiced so much apple juice.
We had gallons and gallons of gallons of apple juice that we put in the freezer.
Freezes are really, really well.
We have a dehydrated, we dehydrated a bunch of apple slices.
And we have a freeze dryer.
We have tons of apples.
So much that we, you're just like, what are we going to do?
We used every apple that we possibly could.
So, I think it's great to have apple trees and fruit trees.
I think it's fantastic.
We have giant beds of strawberries.
We have huge mungus raspberry patch.
I make tons of jam with that.
And we freeze dry a ton of our berries.
They're great for the kids.
It's great kids to eat.
So, but it's how you grow them, what you're, what you're sprayed on them.
Even with apple trees, they're not sprayed round up.
They'd be sprayed something for, the only thing that we'd sprayed the trees for is to keep the worms off of the fruiting bodies so that, you know, that's not an issue.
They wouldn't be keeping fruit on the tree anyhow.
They would be picking the fruit because it wouldn't travel well and it wouldn't sell well.
So, I don't think you have to worry about that.
Okay, so this is the other question about the true rife.
How does the new true rife F122 compare to the older F122 and the F117?
Because there is a difference.
So, I pulled up three pictures here.
So, this picture of the far left is the older F122.
I think it came out in 2020 or 2021.
I can't remember.
Part for me with, I can't remember past dates real well as far as years go.
And the middle picture is that F117 is a newer F117.
And the one of the far right is the new F122 that they sell now.
Notice that there are some differences.
Of course, now the new one does not have these stupid little broom holders on the side of it that Mike used to put on them.
That were handy when you'd wrap up the cord.
It was handy for things like that, but did make it look a little tackier.
And it nearly served no purpose for everyday use.
There was a time that probably nobody on this call can remember that it did serve another purpose in that grounding port where I have these arrows pointed to this grounding port right there.
We used to use this handheld ground.
Especially when you were doing different things.
So when you're using the iron pro wave, you had a ground in pillow that you'd plug into that ground.
Or you'd have a grounding pad that you'd sit on and plug into that ground notice on the new machines.
There's no grounding port there.
So you have to plug the ground, the grounding pad, or if you have a grounding pillow, you have to plug it into an outlet.
There's no considerable difference whatsoever there with that.
The reason why Mike initially put that grounding port on the original F117 was because.
We used to use it with a handheld ground where people would actually hold a ground while they're being treated.
This is the years and years ago and that got phased out a long time ago.
But he kept the grounding port there to plug in the grounding pad. It made perfect sense.
And it also makes perfect sense to we don't really need that because that grounding port then actually went back to the ground of the cord that would then go to your grounded outlet.
So whether you plug it in here or you plug it in outlet, it really doesn't make any difference.
So that is absence, absent also the new F122 there's some things you can't do on it.
So you need to plug the grounding port your ground need pad into it outlet because there's no port there.
It does not support scanning so you guys don't know what scanning is.
There is a GRS scanner that Mike used to sell and we used to scan people in the office.
You scan for different frequencies. Now true I've doesn't even sell that scanner anymore.
Mike used to sell and I say Mike for those who are new who don't know who Mike has Mike used to be Mike used to own true right.
And just sold it the last year and a half. But they don't even sell the GRS scanner anymore.
Mike used to sell a colloidal silver machine. They don't sell that anymore Mike used to sell a an apparatus that you could connect little goggles to and put goggles on and run different frequencies that would stimulate different brain frequency.
They don't sell that anymore. So there's multiple different pieces that true right was just kind of phased out the new true right company is just kind of phased out.
And I know that that has made some people that were followers of Mike and true right through the years and helping support the different research that was done on frequencies and helping come up with different programs to use.
For different diseases. It's kind of made them mad and the new company has kind of alienated a number of people and I've been trying to play the middle man and and calm people's heart style that that hey this is still a great company they're trying to do a lot of good things which I do believe is true.
I think they're doing a lot of good things they're trying to make improvements and just hang in there during any companies you know do changes there's always going to be some difficulties.
And you know there's going to be another question here that I'm going to address on another piece of what can be an issue with any new company and a company trying to make money these days that that's repairing things.
So they don't do a lot of repairs on things that in fact that's why the new true right folders are trying to get people to trade in their F122's because they don't want to have to repair them.
So more Mike was really good at trying to make repairs on things on things this company doesn't have the manpower to do it understand everything costs a lot more money now.
You're going to have employees it costs a lot more money if you're going to have trade employees are not a fixed things like this it costs a lot more money.
And in order to not raise the prices I mean there's all sorts of reasons i'm not going to get into defending all those reasons but it just is what it is.
Trying to get everybody to convert their F117's to F122's gave pretty steep deep discounts for people to trade in their old F117's so they wouldn't even be in the market anymore so people wouldn't be calling them wanting to get them repaired.
So I think the new F122's are an improvement.
They're constantly trying to make good changes and good improvement so I would say you know I'm still 100% behind this company but it those are the things that you just have to look at the differences.
This is that next question my right light bulb has malfunction the cord leading to the bulb has a cut in it so it sparks and causes the bulb to make sizzling noises.
Well that's not good because we're trying to create frequencies to help heal your cancer we're not cooking bacon so sizzling noises are not a good thing to be hearing from your bulb or from the cords question is can this be fixed or can I purchase a new one how would I purchase that what should I do so that's another issue to repair those things they would just say you just need to buy a new one.
I can't repair those things so you know I just don't have the skills to take your bulb apart without losing the gas because your bulb is a gas filled tube and you have to have the machinery to be able to resolder that on correctly and for to work correctly to put a new wire on there so really you just need to get a new one.
You can order it directly from true right or you can order from our website if you order directly from true right if you're going to get their little new model it is a little more expensive I still have some of the older model bulbs on our website I just had a collection of them so
you know you can you can get it from there usually so how does this happen how do you get a cut in the in the cord.
In 99% of the time it's because you got caught underneath a rocking chair or something like that or that's your just like you could get a cut in any extension cord it got snagged on something so.
The worst the biggest thing for the bulbs is a rocking chair so I damaged my cord the same way and had to get a new bulb of a while ago so.
So you can just go on our store in order from our store it's a little it's less expensive because it's the older model but it's still a new bulb.
I got a pet scan today I purchased the radiation holiopad to take to get the radiation out of my system it says to take three drops twice per day but how many days should I take this well I always have said that I think you should just take the whole model because
holiopathy is a great science but nothing is perfect and to get that audio system all you're doing is stimulated your body with holiopathy to have a reaction to help pull it out of the body so taking a radiation holiopath is a way to stimulate your body to help detox radiation just like you take a mercury holiopath to help stimulate your body to detoxify mercury it's the same way.
holiopathy works on an idea that likes cure likes and so I'd say just take it through the bottle which will last you a couple of buds just finish the whole bottle and use that up.
We purchased a growl need sheet and have it across the lower part of the bed so only below the knees touch it but then sleep it with as I feel like I don't sleep as well is there a adjustment time adjustment with this well this that's an odd phenomenon because
if you read the literature on growl need sheets I mean that's one of the things that they push is that people sleep better with it you're going to notice a great change in your sleep you're going to sleep much stronger you're going to have much better sleep to be honest I haven't had anybody ever say that to me that's
since I've been using the growl need sheet I sleep better nobody's ever said that to me nobody's ever said that on the zoom call ever we don't really talk about the growl need sheet that much I have but I also have never heard anybody say that they don't sleep as well with it I would just give it a few more weeks I'd see how you do with it
because I just can't imagine that it would make you sleep worse so I would give it a few more weeks just to make sure that it's not just something else you know that it's going to let you know I'd sleep you I'd give it a little bit more time
the spots where they remove the central lip nodes during my mastectomy surgery are still a bit sore I've seen other women complain about this so I guess it's common any suggestions
well you have wounds there and you have lip vessels that are flowing to nowhere no so it's it's can cause swelling in that area that's not uncommon
and it just takes time to heal that so here when you literally had an organ removed when you have your lip nodes removed so no there's nothing really else you can really do
you could use some collendula lotion on it or some come free lotion on it that might help be helpful and helping it heal better
but no there's there's just you got to give it some time I'm feeling well enough to start working out again and have a gym membership I would like to use
in my rapid weight loss during my bout with staff infection last summer I lost it in a lot of muscle I have gained back plenty of weight so calorie bird is no longer a concern
I have 55 so gated muscle is touted as difficult are there workouts that are normals but unhealthy for a cancer patient
and where do you suggest to begin there was was a trader that specialized in cancer workouts that you interviewed or promoted and it's on the blog post one pointed time are you still in touch with him and do you know if he still offers his discounted services
first I'll dress that no we're not still in touch with him but I don't know that he is still in business that was a number of years ago
he was a local person to be able to say Paul to but back to what should you do and what shouldn't you do so a cancer patient so I've always said that a cancer patient should do exercises that don't bring you to a complete
exoscient so and why is that because cancer cells will reproduce in an anaerobic state not get in too deep into the biology but glucose breaks down through glycolysis to make an end product that then converts to ultimately to
acetylquins of a to go into the crem cycle now cancer cells feed off of lactic acid which isn't in product that will glycolysis will break down to especially in an anaerobic environment
so that's why when you work out really hard you're really sore afterwards that's lactic acid so well that's you're going to produce if you haven't worked out for a while and even if you do some gentle workouts you're going to produce more lactic acid
but you don't want to push it so that you're producing that kind of lactic acid if you're producing a ton of lactic acid in your exercise routine if you don't have any history of cancer well that is a necessary evil in order to be able to be able to convert lactic acid to to pyruvate to acetylquins I may in a more rapid fashion that is what getting initiated
getting in shape is why someone could run two miles in another person and be slightly fatigued and another person can't run more than two blocks without fatigued is because the one who could run two miles is in better shape.
Better shape is defined biologically as they can convert lactic acid into acetylquins I may more rapidly that's what being in shape is and that takes time in order to do that so when you're going to start working out if you have a history of cancer you want to start really slow and gentle
but it might so let's say you're going to try to run two months okay and you have it run for a couple years and running a block is difficult right now start by writing a half a block and stop it you don't want to produce excess lactic acid so you want to go slow well I want to get in shape so I can run two miles for pride out loud how long is it going to take me well you've had cancer and you're older so it's going to take you a while it might take you six months where you can run two miles
you got to be okay with that you don't want to end up being in a state of producing a ton of lactic acid because you just produce a ton of fuel for cancer so don't do that so workout slow and gentle don't be intimidated it's why I don't I'm not a big fan of going to gyms if you ever met an athlete before and you've had cancer because you'll be tempted
because seeing other people that are in a lot better shape you'll be tempted to push yourself and you don't want to push yourself too hard when you've had a history of cancer you want to go slow so you don't want that peer pressure to push yourself harder nor do you want a trader who doesn't understand what I just said because that's what a trader does a trader is there to push you harder to produce more lactic acid to get you in a condition where you can convert lactic acid
to acetylcons that may really super super fast therefore you're getting in shape faster and now you can run five miles in six months and you can run that new that five mile race this summer well that's not what your purposes with cancer you want to go low and slow I would suggest weight lifting doing different weights lighter weights just you know just doesn't roll with being a little sore but if you're really super sore and you could hardly move like oh my gosh I was such a good workout yesterday
I can hardly get off the chair you didn't weigh too much you cannot you do not want to be in that state you have a history of cancer you're just producing cancer food so don't do that is there a time that you no longer load questions for zoom calls is there a way to tell if a question that was submitted was uploaded by you
well if you ask the question on the site and I don't have an on here that you know you didn't get on here so I asked that you try to get your questions in you know half hour before the zoom call that's just my request for you but this question came in two minutes before the zoom call so I just saw it and put it on here so yes I'll try to get questions in as best I
possibly can up to you know right when we do the zoom call but sometimes that's not possible so if you ask a question and it doesn't get on here it just you try to get it in a little
earlier next time so I let up if they get out here it'll be on the next one so if I didn't put your question on the zoom call it will be on the next zoom call unless
it's a question that you've asked multiple times we've had that happen where person has asked the exact same question multiple times that they didn't look at the I answered it at last zoom call and they asked it again you know and because they didn't listen to the last
zoom call they weren't able to get on but they didn't listen to it so I didn't necessarily put that on again because all the people that have jump on and listen to it are regular people are they'd be like you answer that I think you
answered answer this last week so I don't do that if it's a duplicate question but if you ask a question if you posted a question and it didn't get on that week zoom call it would be on the next
week zoom call in my blood test the NK cells are 228 the range is 70 to 760 when the number is closer to the higher range is that does that mean the immune system is better or it is
fighting something or some kind of infection that is why the number is higher save with a CD3 to CD16 ratio
yeah so when you look at that that's the problem when you when you look at a differentiation
now usually if you do CBC with a differential it's only going to measure neutrophils the differential is breaking down to the white blood cells into lymphocytes
neutrophils monocytes blah blah blah it's not going to break it down deeper into NK cells natural which are natural killer cells
and all the other CD cell line unless you do a deep dive in it and there's argument whether the deep dive
with a value of the deep dive I don't recommend it even though one of the best tests for that is a Syrex
I forgot what it is gray 23 I think it is that does the deep dive into that but that's really really before
immune dysfunction patients and that would be autoimmune issues not really even beneficial for cancer patients
um and the reason is is that yes you can have elevated or suppressed
immune function most likely due to either current infection or an autoimmune disorder so having
220 eight you're right in the middle that's normal it would only be you know you could take all the
immune you could take bottles of immune stimulating supplements and it's probably not going to increase your
natural killer cells because your body has a balance of what it's trying to achieve you can't
artificially change that because you're fighting a disease um so you can support it so that your
body can make so it's not depressed so that it's not so it's able to keep up the demand that your
body's making but you can't just take a whole bunch of immune stimulation and think that your white
blood cell count is going to be is going to be elevated by simply doing that so no it's usually because
you're fighting something or it's maybe you could also be in a hyper response in an autoimmune
situation or if it's suppressed depressed you could have a suppressed immune situation
also the you can't forget that you have to correlate to any medication that you're taking because
medication can affect your bone marrow and production of white blood cells as well how are you making
fruit jams that artful of sugar do you have a good sugar-free or low sugar recipe
um you can if you get the shurgel which I do use shurgel I know there's recipes to make jams
without the pectin but I use pectin in my fruit jams that I make you can make the low sugar
portion in the shurgel recipe they do have a recipe for that personally I don't do the low sugar
you just don't eat a lot of jams I mean you're not you're only putting a tablespoon of jams on your
bread or whatever you use it of course you're not like you're eating the whole jar full of jams so
I'm not that concerned about that um I love making jams that's one of my favorite things to make so
I make blueberry jam raspberry jam strawberry jam uh this summer I found wild grapes at our office
which was a really fun find I'd used them we had a gallon of grape juice and I thought well you
don't drink grape juice I thought I'm gonna make jam out of it so I made grape jelly out of it it was
really fun so it's first time I ever made grape jelly um we give our jam away our kids and our
grandkids um our who eat most of our jams so something I just like making I like doing it it's
something I really enjoy doing is kidding so I know it's weird for a guy to like to do that but I
really like to do kidding hot water bath and pressure kidding pressure can a lot of meat um when we
lived it we used to live up in the woods on 280 acres and we were off grid so we didn't have
really refrigeration options we had a fairly small propane refrigerator with a little teeny
witty freezer so freezing meat just not it just was an option you know we only had a few solar panels
so and we had propane lights so and we used mainly kerosene lamps in our house so we didn't have
refrigeration so we had to learn how to can so when we got a deer which I mean you could literally
step off our deck and shoot a deer literally and um we would we'd butcher it up and can it
so and found that canned meat is the best it's just absolutely the best because it's just tender
you could even take a pork cut and meat and pressure can it and you just have the best you know
be strogan off or medicine strogan off in the world so we got into doing that homestead
stuff back before it was cool um with in this generation there's a lot of people doing it which
is really really exciting but we used we've done that you know for back in the 90s when we lived
up in the woods uh do you put the radiation homeopath drops in your mouth directly or you put it
in water no just put it right under your tongue when it directly in your mouth and remember with
the radiation with any homeopathy you want to be 15 to 30 minutes away from any food and 15 to
30 minutes away from any mint mint yeah your toothpaste so um you don't have mint toothpaste
in the world but most toothpastees these days have some sort of peppermint or spearmint or something
like that so you don't like to have that in your mouth at all when you're doing the homeopathy
do we need to sleep with ground-in sheets no and if you do use a ground-in sheet you will
use it on the lower half of your body so you put it across your whole bed on the lower half of your bed
um the person who asked a question about it said they used it for their d-style but you could do it
from your trunk down from your buttocks down um you put the ground-in sheet on the lower half of your
bed underneath your fitted sheet is there a detox homeopathy product for arsenic um there is um
yes there is let me let me look around quick it is um see the detox
the questions is on back order um and the amalgam oh let me look
the hp let me look here real quick um the adics that's the one game we couldn't think of
so the adics let's see if it has no it doesn't if you want that I can make it for you
um don't think uh I think the detox the questions from php hasn't but they're on back order so
if you want call Megan and I can make you that so I can create the hollo path for arsenic for you
specifically so just call Megan in the store tomorrow uh we had specials probably still be there for a
while today but you call her and tell her that we talked on the zoom call and remind her and I will
make you a model for arsenic I used that personal trader last year check out the nonprofit survival
strength.org I got six months free uh I could also text um yes that's a guy's name and see if he
still connected to that nonprofit thank you for that information I received my model of clear
hissed and clear CV today and see that they both been reformulated can you tell me about the changes
and why they were done um so the clear CV we wanted to add vitamin A to it because by the synergistic
effects of those things for clear CV to help with with colds and viruses I want it was just missing
vitamin A so we switched it to add vitamin A so that's really the only difference in clear CV.
The clear hiss formula is a little bit different um because we we just went to we switched to a
different company with that that I was happier with with the total product itself so the clear hiss
there's more it's it's a similar product but there's more changes to it um I just think it's a much
better product or I was just searching to get to give you the best products especially products I have
our names on it we want the best product out there there's the website for who's asked that question
survival2strike.com survival2strike.com thank you for that what any a few drops of folic
minerals to my SCAC TV okay for me I read that it can't enhance the absorption into the cells with
the addition of folic minerals so I don't know which folic minerals that you're talking about
so let me look up to your if I already talked if I already gave you the okay um that mineral then
yes you can if if you're like no I just came up with this myself you didn't even look at the
folic minerals for me then I need to look at them because there's minerals out there that are
earthbound minerals that are liquid minerals that I just very much against and I actually created a
couple blog posts on that why do I not like ionic minerals I think is the blog post um and I
explained in that video um why I don't like ionic minerals because they're not um they're not
key-lated the way that we're supposed to eat minerals so we get our minerals normally um from
plants yeah so here's the blog post right here
and it looks like this so if you search for that why I don't like liquid ionic minerals you'll
understand so if you can send me if you can send me the the product I could look at it a little bit deeper
arsenic detox call magnet thank you yes your answer to my workout question was helpful thank you I
used to do peak eights so h i i t exercise is the best exercise for your heart bar none so that means
you're doing um you're basically doing intervals when I used to be in track we'd run intervals and
I was in cross-country a track and you run as fast as you can for a period of time you're running
400 meter intervals or 800 meter intervals and then you have a period of rest that you go again
and you go as hard as you possibly can that is the has been proven to be absolutely the best exercise
for your heart because that's the exercise that you'd use to build blood vessels so that's what
stimulates blood vessel production so it stimulates vajaph so that's the vascular endothelial growth
factor that's what stimulates that but the thing is when you have cancer you don't want to stimulate
vascular endothelial growth factor I mean that's you do not want to stimulate that so
um you know that I didn't even touch on that point but you're also what you're doing that you know
working to exhaustion put it yourself in a completely anaerobic state giving the cancer it's
fuel to grow so you don't want to do that when you have a history of cancer I consider the private
cardio detox yes so you don't want to do that with cancer so if you want more information what you
can contact him Dina and see it's really not the platform to be talking back and forth if
that's all right any other questions and someone explain so I want to explain once that if you can
carry on a conversation while working out you're still in the aerobic zone yeah I would say
you know to a point um you can kind of fake is you're carrying out a conversation and
and still be panting like a dog underneath so just be careful you're not pushing it so yeah but I
would say that's a good that's a good thing that's a good marker I would say if you can freely carry
out a conversation you're talking you're probably in the aerobic zone I think that's a good marker
to follow all right with that I think we'll say goodbye um and um we have some announcements that are
going to be coming up in this next week so make sure you check the member site um then we'll talk
about him at the zoom call next week as well all right love you all we'll talk again next week bye bye